y como decía la presentación mi nombre
es gilberto alcaraz pero me gusta más
presentarme como como un pueblerino muy
bien adaptado a la ciudad y es que creo
que la gente de pueblo tenemos una
ventaja que es que vemos las cosas mucho
más fáciles creemos que todo es más
sencillo y de hecho nos da la
oportunidad de seguir persiguiendo
nuestros sueños probablemente por mucho
más tiempo yo nací en un pueblo en
jalisco llamado ciudad guzmán jalisco de
150.000 habitantes que al que le ha
dolido toda la vida muchísimo que le
digan pueblo tanto hasta que se cambió
el nombre de su ciudad pero en realidad
es un pueblo y la característica de este
pueblo creo yo es que conviven tres
mundos importantes que es el mundo rural
desde luego el típico mundo de los
pueblos pero también el artístico es un
pueblo que está lleno de artistas y
también de locos
y siempre ha pertenecido al tercer al
tercer grupo pero por ejemplo para este
lugar los ídolos locales son gente como
juan josé arreola y josé clemente orozco
con solito velázquez esos son los ídolos
locales es atípico en un lugar de estas
características y lo que me parece que
permaneció es que en cada barrio en cada
colonia en cada lugar en cuentas
artistas músicos poetas pintores de
hecho mi familia materna precisamente
está ligada totalmente a la pintura mi
madre es historiadora del arte en cada
lugar y siendo un lugar muy pequeñito
y ahí fue donde decidí
cuando era niño que lo que yo quería
hacer en la vida era ser un superhéroe y
sé que cualquiera medio día pues todos
los niños en algún momento de su vida
quieren ser un superhéroe sí pero yo
realmente lo intenté lo intenté en serio
al grado de que soy muy recordado
precisamente en mi pueblo oportunidad me
subí a la azotea con una toalla en la
espalda y me aventé entonces lo intente
de verdad no intente también intentar
meterme al colegio militar en esta época
de los 80s en que los santiagos serán
precisamente militares de verdad yo
quería ser un superhéroe
bueno definitivamente no no me convertí
en un superhéroe estudie mercadotecnia
soy mercado luego desde hace 25 años soy
apasionado profundamente de mi carrera
de mi de lo que hago todos los días que
es trabajar con las marcas cada
reputación hacer estrategias comerciales
y trabajo he hecho para una de las 50
marcas más importantes de este país y en
los últimos años me he dedicado justo a
eso a trabajar ahí pero entendiendo
precisamente desde mi carrera que los
mercados lo que hacemos es tratar de
entender qué es lo que motiva a las
personas me di cuenta que mi intención
de ser un superhéroe precisamente estaba
motivada por querer ayudar porque debe
hacer algo más por los demás y desde
joven inclusive antes de entrar a la
carrera organizaba con mi familia en las
navidades llevarle juguetes a las
comunidades menos afortunadas
últimamente con los migrantes que las
han de comer trabajar en en actividades
que tuvieran que ver con trascender no
simplemente hacer lo que hacemos todos
los días sino ver qué más podemos hacer
por los demás
siempre siempre me ha motivado y siempre
ha sido una cuestión que ha estado
presente en mi vida
como les decía el trabajo para para una
de las marcas más importantes del país
hecho la más reconocida a nivel de
pinturas y en este proceso entre a
cómics
precisamente la posición más pequeñita
que tenían de mercadotecnia y
honestamente me aburría muchísimo yo
quería ser muchísimo más y empecé a ver
en ese momento que el arte urbano a
nivel mundial estaba teniendo un auge
que estaba empezando a tomar la ciudad
yo trabajaba en guadalajara y empecé a
ver que inclusive en guadalajara estaba
viendo expresiones artísticas
maravillosas y busque a uno de estos
artistas que me pareció que tenía
realmente una gran técnica y tenía mucho
que aportar y precisamente conocí al pp
el pp este personaje que además coincide
que cuando lo busco me enteró que estaba
detenido que estaba en la cárcel
precisamente por haber pintado un mural
en ese momento el arte urbano no era
bien bien visto entonces movilizando me
con otras personas pues logramos sacarlo
a pagar su fianza resarcir el daño de
las personas que habían se habían visto
afectadas y ayudarlos precisamente a que
pudieran estar soportados por una
empresa que les diera respaldo que para
cuando llegaran a una universidad o
llegaron a un gobierno y decir vamos a
hacer algo
algo de arte
porque ellos se autonombran neo
muralistas mexicanos y tienen mucha
razón pues precisamente tuvieron el
respaldo de una compañía que los ayudará
hicimos una alianza tanto con el pp como
con ive que los verán ahí en la
fotografía para estarlos apoyando y que
hicieran esto de gran tamaño inclusive
durante los juegos panamericanos y al
gobierno nos permitió hacer una
intervención que recordará que ahí se
ven jugados los juegos panamericanos y
que fueron murales de gran tamaño que se
hicieron en la ciudad de guadalajara
pero después de casi 8 años de relación
y de hacer proyectos por todo el país e
ir sembrando este este concepto del arte
urbano en distintos lugares llegó un
proyecto que la verdad hizo un gran
cambio en como empecé a ver yo el arte
urbano y lo que estábamos haciendo un
proyecto en miravalle en el cual en
combinación con el ayuntamiento de
guadalajara nos invitan a entrar a una
de las colonias con mayor índice de
criminalidad en guadalajara de hecho la
seguridad pública no puede entrar con
índices de violencia altísimo con
desconexión entre ellos entre los
vecinos pleitos constantes
y nos invitaron a hacer una intervención
ahí
movilizado con las conocidas no había
posibilidad de que entraba la seguridad
pública y finalmente entraron este grupo
de artistas urbanos llegaron al lugar al
principio fue muy complicado pero
después de algunas semanas fui a
visitarlos para ver cómo iba este
proyecto y para sorpresa mía lo que me
encontré es que se habían vuelto los
héroes locales se habían encontrado con
que la gente los adoptaba y estos niños
jóvenes adultos mayores las señoras les
daban de comer todo el día en su casa y
se habían vuelto realmente los héroes
del lugar en pocas palabras los habían
adoptado y si les platicó que cuando
llegaron que además los vieron en la
fotografía tienen más pinta de
pandilleros tips son gente que viene de
fuera no estaba no son de ahí llegan a
una comunidad con grandes conflictos y
de repente los reciben algo acá algo
cambio o un cambio profundo lo que
estaba pasando ahí y platicando con
ellos convive con perico y qué pasó qué
está sucediendo en la comunidad y me
platicaron que pues sí al inicio los
habían rechazado pero
conforme ellos se iban acercando
explicarles que lo que iban a hacer era
este mural en un edificio en medio de
esta comunidad para celebrar que había
un proceso de pacificación que había un
proceso de querer hacer las cosas
distintas de qué miravalle no fuera
reconocido simple sencillamente como un
lugar violento la gente empezó a cambiar
y empezó a platicar con ellos y les
empezó a abrir sus puertas y se
volvieron como les digo ídolos en el
lugar
y en este momento mi conclusión es algo
así como que pareciera que el color
llegó y toco su ser y precisamente hizo
un cambio profundo en lo que estaban
viendo no parecía casi mágico pero
déjenme platicarles además que yo tengo
un tema con este tipo de cosas que
parecen casi mágicas cuando yo tenía
entre 10 y 11 años estaba en sexto de
primaria mis papás vivíamos en ciudad
guzmán so se van a vivir a toluca y yo
me quedo en lo que terminaba la primaria
con mis abuelos y la altura de la ciudad
de toluca mi mamá que nació con un
problema cardíaco sufría sufría
muchísimo y esto necesitaba doctores
cada rato y uno de estos doctores que le
recomendaron era un doctor de estos de
técnicas alternativas que trabajan por
imposición de manos cuando la ve me dice
que ella nació con un don y que ella
tiene la posibilidad de ayudar a más
personas y que tendría que hacerlo para
no hacer la historia larga después de
meses la convence se involucra en su
consultorio y entiendo que fueron muy
exitosos
tan exitosos como para llamar la
atención de uno de los programas de
televisión más importantes del país en
ese momento en canal en el canal
principal en horario premium y los
invitan a dar una demostración de lo que
no les dijeron es que en realidad lo que
quería el canal era mostrarlos como
charlatanes que no estaban haciendo
realmente nada sino simple y
sencillamente estaban engañando a las
personas
llevaron pacientes falsos doctores y
pues el resultado fue precisamente que
los exhibieron como si estuvieran
haciendo un daño a la sociedad
yo tenía 10 11 años vivía en un pueblo y
lo vieron millones de personas a través
del país incluyendo mi pueblo y se
imaginarán que esto no fue una etapa
fácil en mi vida porque el bullying con
el que yo viví un tiempo fue bastante
bastante pesado con el tiempo pasó y
como todos los fortalece
pero no fue fácil y desde ese momento
encuentro que yo tengo una especie de
bloqueo para este tipo de soluciones
respecto muchísimo todos aquellos
tratamientos y todo lo que se ofrece de
justine yo tengo un bloqueo de niño de
que ese tipo de cosas a mí lo que me
generó fue más dolor un beneficio
cuando me regreso a los murales y veo
que lo que estábamos viendo aquí era
casi mágico mi primer reacción es esto
es imposible o sea no puede existir que
siempre y sencillamente el color cambie
la vida de las personas y me puse a
investigar y me encontré para sorpresa
que si hay tres teorías que me dieron
soporta que esto sí es real y que esto
no está inventado la primera es con la
que trabajo todos los días que es la
teoría del color en donde decimos que el
color de ciertos colores generan
comportamientos y patrones de la gente y
ésta está documentado el segundo es la
teoría de las ventanas rotas que nace de
un experimento que se hace en stamford
en 1969 en donde el doctor philip sin
embargo involucra una comunidad que
estaba deteriorada y donde dice que un
espacio deteriorado lastimado hace que
la gente se sienta lastimado y
deteriorada y que si tú cambias el
espacio
precisamente haces un cambio en la
sociedad en esta teoría en este
experimento está basada la autoridad de
las ventanas rotas que hoy es una de las
teorías de para prevención de
criminalidad a nivel mundial más
y que se se mostró en los 80s y por
último hay unos muy buenos casos en
latinoamérica y probablemente algunos de
ellos lo han conocido en brasil y en
medellín en colombia en donde en el caso
de brasil en la favela de vila cruzeiro
un grupo de holandeses llegó e hizo
murales en una de las favelas más
violentas de brasil y empezó a ver un
cambio comunitario
ghazi jan llegaron hicieron este proceso
en un pedacito de esa favela y empezó a
ver un cambio social y el otro es
medellín en el que no hicieron murales
simple y sencillamente significaron el
espacio hicieron construcciones dignas
bibliotecas parques de recreo y también
ningún cambio social ahí entonces
primero ya no estaba
esa parte mágica que me impedía seguir
trabajando por ahí pero honestamente en
cuanto desapareció esa magia apareció la
magia de verdad y empezamos a darnos
cuenta que sin querer en el caso de
miravalle lo que estábamos haciendo era
precisamente un proyecto de impacto
social un proyecto que estaba
transformando una comunidad porque no
solamente fueron los murales
fue la labor de estos artistas urbanos
que se fueron a vivir allí por un tiempo
que convivieron con la gente que los
entendieron que les dieron la
oportunidad de verse con otros ojos y
además mostrarse ante otros ojos de una
manera distinta además el gobierno
cuando vio todo este proceso desde luego
que entró en la seguridad pública
bajaron los índices de criminalidad se
hicieron procesos de pacificación
adentro y hasta el día de hoy siguen
pasando cosas en este lugar de hecho
esta es una nota del 2017 donde la
comunidad organizada están presentando
los nuevos talleres socioproductivos
iniciamos un cambio ahí que continúa y
que inició precisamente a partir del
color a partir de lo que empezamos a
hacer con ellos y entonces se me ocurre
la idea de llegar con la empresa y
decirles vamos a hacer algo con esto
esto no lo podemos dejar desapercibido
vamos a quitarle dinero a la publicidad
y vamos a meterlo acá con la promesa de
lo prometo de que vamos a tener igual o
más repercusión con la marca sí sí
haciendo esto si el dinero que
invertimos una parte de lo que
invertimos en publicidad lo ponemos aquí
no vamos a perder ese pequeño alcance
que tenemos con la publicidad lo vamos a
potenciar acá
honestamente no fue fácil convencerlos
mi jefe estaba tan emocionado como yo
pero mucho más escéptico y me dijo bueno
vamos a hacer un ejercicio y vamos a
intentarlo el primer año
el primer año no fue nada fácil lo
primero la verdad fue encontrar más
personas que pudieran creer en esto y
que nos ayudaron a contribuir a que esto
realmente se volviera realidad dos
personas clave my hernández quien tomó
esta idea y se puso a investigar y
trabajar con sociólogos con antropólogos
para ver cómo sucedía este proceso de
cambio como teníamos que darle un cambio
realmente y cuál era la metodología que
teníamos que seguir y ella le dio forma
y lo convirtió precisamente en un
programa social y lidia fresedo que se
encargó de convertir esto en una
historia para compartirlo con los medios
y con las personas porque los medios
aquí juegan un factor un factor clave en
función de que la gente se vea en los
medios dice aquí se está pasando algo y
el poder de convencimiento es mucho más
alto
y la otra parte son los aliados que te
ayudan a hacer esto y encontramos tres
germen club que son este primer grupo de
grafiteros de artistas urbanos que
encontré mi bp que que nos ayudaron
porque además ellos venían saliendo de
un mundo de drogas a partir del arte
urbano dejaron las drogas y dedicaron
inclusive parte de su vida a ayudar a
chicos que estaban ahí y que han sido un
gran aliado en este proceso colectivo
tomate que es una idea de tres chicos
que se encargan de vincular artistas con
comunidades y hacer un trabajo profundo
social y en los últimos meses
precisamente la güera kuri que va a
estar aquí en unos minutos más que nos
ha ayudado a también desde esta parte
del fútbol sin género y de darle la
oportunidad a las personas que
encuentren en cualquier espacio
oportunidades para hacer hemos hemos
hecho este vínculo con ellos de los
cuales además hemos aprendido muchísimo
porque ellos viven con la gente
comunican lo que pasa y nos dicen qué es
lo que le duele a las personas
como les decía el primer año no fue
fácil pero también fue maravilloso lo
que encontramos fue cómo se involucraba
la comunidad comunidades donde cuando
llegas tocas la puerta lo primero que te
dicen es no quiero nada de qué partido
vienes no quiero saber nada de aquí y
que los que te reciban y que les digas
que vas a hacer un proceso de murales y
que vas a contar sus historias porque lo
que cuentan los murales son las
historias de la comunidad lo que pasa y
lo que la gente quiere que sepa estamos
tan individualizados en este mundo tan
metidos en nuestros dispositivos que hoy
hemos dejado de saber quién vive al lado
de nuestras casas cuando hace años
conocíamos a todos los vecinos jugábamos
con todos hoy es muy probable que la
persona que vive al lado de ti no sepas
quién es y no sabes qué le pasa y a lo
mejor parte de lo que tú haces podría
ayudarle a mejorar su vida esto es lo
que hemos venido trabajando el proceso
de reconstitución del tejido social ha
sido acelerado hemos hemos tocado la
vida de muchísima gente y además estamos
siendo reconocidos como el programa de
impacto social más grande del país y uno
de los más grandes de latinoamérica hoy
inclusive buscando el registro con la
unesco cual ha sido al alcance casi
200.000 metros cuadrados intervenidos y
regresados a la comunidad que llevan un
trabajo de entre tres meses y dos años
dependiendo de la complejidad
esto equivale a casi 30 canchas del
estadio azteca más de 100 mil litros de
pintura 40 ciudades 50 500 artistas y un
equipo de personas que hacen labor con
la comunidad los murales solamente
celebran lo que hay paso pero somos un
profundo estudio de qué es lo que le
duele a la comunidad qué es lo que la
tiene desconectada y lo más importante
es que hemos tocado la vida de más de
dos millones de personas 700 mil que
viven en nuestras comunidades y que han
sido partícipe para este cambio la
realidad es que ese no es un programa
asistencialista nosotros no damos nada
lo que hacemos es trabajar con ellos
para que esto cambie y para la compañía
estas ha vuelto a la estrategia de
mercadotecnia más rentable que tenemos
para generar precisamente publicidad no
pagada pero además es el generador
número uno de nuestras reputacionales
positivas para la compañía el resultado
ha sido muy positivo ahí hemos vivido y
hemos visto el méxico que no nos gusta
violento controlado por el crimen
organizado utilizado por organizaciones
políticas para otros fines
hemos visto ese méxico que no nos gusta
y que queremos cambiar pero también
hemos visto este méxico lleno de
esperanza en donde la gente tiene ganas
de salir a decir que está pasando algo
distinto cuando la empodera esta gente y
le dices habla como comunidad y empodera
te para que vayas transformando tu
espacio la gente lo hace mucha gente se
me acerca y me pregunta cómo puedo sumar
vayan a estas comunidades involucren sé
y lo que más le duele a esta gente este
paciente estigmatizada que se siente a
un lado se siente rechazado como no van
a vivir agresivos y se sienten
rechazados por sus espacios por su gente
por las ciudades en donde habitan y una
cosa muy importante que fue una
revelación para mí es no tienes que
dedicarle tiempo a ir a ayudar personas
tienes que hacer lo que haces todos los
días en beneficio de la gente y así fue
como encontré ello desde la estrategia
de mercadotecnia la posibilidad de
cambiar la vida de millones de personas
y tratar de hacer con esto un méxico
bien hecho muchas gracias
[Aplausos]